okay [ __ ] can't talk to the switching
substation it's a boy psycho battle here
or playing a continuation of fires in
the sky so let's knock and do this and
conduct where are you taking dog hard to
put dog nope hmm says hey carrying with
me I now he'll I remember you you were
mean to dog dog has heard that and dog
was home dog doesn't want to go to gauge
its instant the lights worked uh-huh
Matt Hasina master would but
dog hears many voices met you is he
coming I can't he saw if I can go how do
I get him together remember you you will
meet dog dog
okay okay I got good only get some
[ __ ] help okay south park NJ and
stretch out some parking bans um I got
my boy kanya here it's not what you said
us oh [ __ ] where's my weapon then okay
okay dog was getting home yeah yeah it's
a great now you know and I don't know
how I can feel about that [ __ ] I don't
know how I feel about [ __ ] this
expenditure I don't think it's a cure
yeah there's good things in life like
check in and peers but why
yes yes ah there's good things like like
cheese it like salt like that and
there's bad things like diarrhea like
hey man you know I just
oh yeah he's a conscious all right [ __ ]
all right try to take this now I know
sometimes people are you talking this
boy toy you know good boy toy okay I'll
take that sausage okay don't have
anything good and 1927 ok I'll just be
the shell if you guys went up there like
an egg [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah eat them
back on yet get it down eat head bench
eat hip [ __ ]
okay okay it was i he ready i thinks i
was i wasn't canlas j good good that's
the word okay can't sleep this off ok
good [ __ ] eight speakers make good
[ __ ] food I think the cram oh well it
is nice this is nice speech
survival let's just get that up don't
worry about that okay let's do this
figure out exactly where I gotta go you
know I'm saying you know what I am
saying I'm gonna rock [ __ ] away okay
where's the best oh [ __ ] beat this [ __ ]
down cognac beetle Pinot Pinot you know
again hit him again is it where is it
there I know he is our conscience no try
take these eyes shut they all have them
bear trap fest dog food oh [ __ ] how's
that
toggi [ __ ] ahead of off your [ __ ]
animal wait honey these guys now i cant
dog his following place with hard to
pull I can't get any kings is over there
don't be resting
reset it why are we here dog not want to
be here place too much like a cage if
dog was fed like last dog doesn't under
if dog was maybe voice could make dog
stay dog not one okay where is your God
now all right
can I get in this day why are we here if
dog [ __ ] yep and don't have the dog stay
thing [ __ ] today get rid of that that
data miss are you talk oh yeah these
switches won't move themselves after you
can lead me to water no being trapped in
this court I can survive one or two of
the inhabitants more than that and the
gate here if it's some help huh really
you're right no I can help you I we just
need to MIT dog has torn apart a number
of the inner find some of the
inhabitants it'll require some hunt
they're not easy to kill
two chunks of me okay okay uh anyway
just like hella much all right let's
just beat this [ __ ] down okay
where's the other one and I is in here
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] I can like hear the
[ __ ] anyway it went over here right
ouch what the flying [ __ ] come on oh
yeah wow that did like [ __ ] nothing
howdy get [ __ ] out that can exit exit
it's gonna be dope dude ouch i keep on
getting [ __ ] hurt by that thing
they're bad you better have brought
enough you're cool ok
you